in the white pieces moving out his
knight yep it's the reti opening as we
call it named after the hungarian player
richard retty and magnus actually used
this already earlier in the champions
chess tour earlier in the charity cup
uh just a very quiet way of starting the
game very flexible just keeping your
pawns in the center back for now and
throwing them down the board later just
depending on what your opponent does
first white just getting ready to fiance
with the bishop just creating a nice
home for it and actually
i don't want to talk about myself too
much but i did play jordan van priest
last year in the mr dodgy invitational
in it was a blitz tournament i played
this opening against him every single
time with white just because his
openings are too good here you just
survive the opening it's actually very
symmetrical especially if black brings
out his knight is almost completely
symmetrical now and uh you just get out
of the opening very stable position
and you go from there also
these two faced each other at the
beginning of this year in a classical
game over the board and they had a very
similar opening this uh to this one
maybe even this exact position
uh so yeah just i think this is good
strategy from magnus just taking things
very slow at the beginning um no
fireworks because that would only favor
the young dutchman yeah and you're
totally right they're actually repeating
their game from tata steel
and that game ended in a draw okay and
that was one of the most exciting draws
i've ever seen so not all draws are
equal not all draws are boring
um that game that they had in january
over the board first magnus was winning
then he was almost losing then he was
winning again then he was almost losing
and it was a very deep kind of strategic
battle yeah so magnus now just gaining
space this is his kind of trademark move
just gaining space on the queen side
with his pawns as much as possible at an
early stage yeah and it is an early
stage actually to make that porn move i
mean it hasn't been played before even
though it is a kind of typical idea in
this particular position
i mean white wants to gain as much space
as possible on the left side of the
board and
jordan reacting in a very thematic way
actually just jumping into the center
with his knight
white has a few options white can step
forward with the king's pawn reinforce
the center can also develop the knights
to
the square in front of the queen just
challenging putting pressure on black
central knight
and uh
maybe he can use both knights actually
can go to that square if he wants to be
a bit clever
so those are the three main moves and
it's funny because uh okay until
magnus's last move we were also
following a game of mine against laurent
fresney our guest from that break
so
yeah i mean this is the universe you
guys i know it's this small bubble of
magnus carlsen and all his friends just
seem to have all i mean this is their
battleground basically
and
also i mean we saw that video of jordan
helping
lauren helping i think it's an unwritten
rule among friends among people who
study together you don't play
any opening you've discussed in the past
because that's kind of just that
territory is off
off bounds you just
it feels a bit sneaky if you have
studied something before uh together and
then you use it against uh against your
friends so
i think magnus just trying to get a
position that they haven't really
discussed together and uh
going from there now this tends to be
like the natural strategy when you've
studied together you just choose
openings that you haven't worked on and
i remember there's a very famous story
in the english chess community um
between two grand masters who lived
together oh and they were playing each
other in the british championships and
they you know they walked out all the
the lines that they had studied they
made all the moves and they agreed to
draw at the end of it and another grand
master came and looked at what they
played and was like aha so that's what
you got prepared and it was the day it
was in the days before computers and he
found a hole in their preparation he
found a mistake
and
when
this grand master faced off against our
two friends
well he won both of them yeah he just
yeah he won that one game yeah and uh
yeah and after that they were like these
two friends were like we are never ever
going to be revealing our prep
so uh yeah definitely uh don't reveal
your secrets yeah chess players are
sneaky so yeah that's not to reveal too
much to them yeah yeah
and i also just wanted to mention that
uh we
even though you know we are raising
money for unicef we still want to get
enthusiastic about the chess and we
still want everyone to join in the fun
and the conversation and so we really
appreciate it when everyone sends us
their questions their thoughts and even
their selfies and you can do all this by
tweeting us using the hashtag
chesschamps
and we will feature them on the show if
they come at the right time and if you
have a really cool costume at all why
not take a picture of it with you in the
costume it would be we need some humor
as well we need some good mood as well
we'd love to see you in your costume and
the tinky winky costume uh two hours
left to make your bid
it's currently only on 111
so you could make a bargain for a very
cool costume at the same time of course
and most importantly
donating money to unicef which is so so
important you guys this is the moment to
help the people in ukraine
and we have kira from unicef in in the
studio here uh we've been talking about
the people of course at the border
people so many people becoming refugees
but i'm wondering for the millions of
people still inside ukraine and where
bombs are hitting how are parents and
people able to protect themselves and
protect their children
i don't know i mean it's
i mean of course people go into the bomb
shelters right
but i i think one of the most important
things now is that we
we we also have to to in a way demand uh
that the war stops and also we we have
to um to bring up the international
humanitarian law a a
ihl which is so important um ihl says
that you cannot bomb hospitals for
instance okay
but we have seen more than 30 hospitals
being being being bombed during the war
now and that is a break of international
humanitarian law so we need to talk
about these things also uh because
hospital cells are supposed to be safe
places
in the war
and uh well and now now they're not and
i i guess for for the unicef people on
the ground and also of course for
children and mothers giving birth that
is just uh
horrible it's horrible yeah
so important you guys that we donate and
help unicef help the people inside
ukraine we do see some moves coming out
are all pieces still on the board yes
and uh usually we'd say that favors
jordan just because he likes tension he
likes being able to be creative later in
the game and the more pieces the better
when it comes to creativity but then
again
right now white does have a little bit
more space if we look at the pawn
structure
maybe we can jump into the position just
to show what's going through both
players minds so
magnus he's just maneuvered his knight
around he used the side of the board
which we don't normally recommend but
the knight is heading back towards the
center and if white gets one more move
he's actually going to bring his knight
even closer to the center eyeing up this
bishop also putting extra pressure on
black's central pawn and the reason
white tends to have a tiny at least
practical advantage in these positions
is because white holds the key to the
center if you look at these two pawns if
you compare them to black's pawns
black's pawns are slightly more passive
white is the one deciding whether to
lock it up by pushing forward later
gaining a bit more space or whether to
trade and just maybe make things
completely symmetrical black meanwhile
doesn't want to be the one releasing
that tension because if black ever
trades the pawns it would only help
white to establish a strong central
influence so um yeah right now just this
kind of lock and key
tension in the center slightly favors
white also this pawn a bit more advanced
than its rival over here and magnus
likes these things for end games if it
becomes a pawn race his pawns are
further advanced
so meanwhile jordan he would like to
maybe release the tension in the center
i can imagine him bringing his rook
across bringing his queen out
okay he actually retreats his bishop
he's trying to force magnus's hand so
he's actually putting some pressure on
this pawn indirectly
so now he is threatening to win a pawn
but the bishop is a bit of a clumsy
piece it looks like it's just locked
behind its own pawns now and that's the
second time he's moved it he's spent a
couple of moves now and it's still a
passive square so i'm expecting magnus
to maybe just back up this pawn again
with his knight
just to give it extra protection with
the pawn and night now and uh still very
very tense
uh personally i slightly prefer white
here but anything can happen later on
and maybe jordan's got ambitious
intentions this is what happened in the
game in january he started throwing
pawns down the board towards the white
king
so yeah very very tense and both players
spending a couple of minutes so far i'm
expecting them to
because it's okg spend even more time in
this middle game with all pieces still
on the board
okay and i was just going to point out
um
yeah but i was just going to point out
that there is a little bit of a trap in
the position um white would also you
know player like myself would love to
push the pawn forward and get my little
big clamp into operation you know that's
my favorite thing not to clam but clamp
clamp clamp sorry oh oh
no no
but this is this move isn't really
possible because you have a knight takes
pawn on the board knight takes pawn and
that utilizes the fact that there's uh
actually tension between these bishops
this central pawn for white is actually
pinned so if you go and capture this
night now your bishop your dark squad
bishop will drop and in the process
black would have won a pawn
it's even better than that for black
because this pawn is weak and the bishop
pair in the process so white can't lock
things up as predicted he has
centralized his knight
and now these two knights are just
fantastic pieces black's knight as well
is pretty good right now but uh that
being said black does have ways to
undermine white's knight firstly by
maybe throwing this pawn down the board
to try and kick it off its central
square or by utilizing this bishop
this is maybe
a riskier move because this bishop is on
a great square already as we showed just
in that last variation this is a great
diagonal but you could maybe bring your
bishop to the side of the board and hint
at capturing this knight for example if
white just plays a quiet move now then
you could capture this knight and
white's pawn structure now is shattered
as we saw in the last game with uh
pragnanda against magnus
often having these type of type of
double pawns it's okay for now but long
term they could become weaknesses and
white's king would be slightly airy and
okay i'm very surprised by this move i
must admit jordan normally plays towards
his opponent's king but here he hasn't
pushed on the king's side he's pushed on
the opposite flank and he really hates
this tension with the pawns here he's
trying to force white to make a decision
it's all about this guy right now and
the pawns just staring down at each
other and uh if we do see a trade for
example of pawns on this left side then
at least now pieces are starting to come
off and
when
you have a space disadvantage like
jordan has even if it's tiny trading
pieces does help it gives your pieces
more space to work with
so kira when you play in the in the
challenge
after this game
will it be a strategy to keep pieces on
the board is that a good strategy to
last as many moves as possible i think
i'll try to make a bit of a
defensive position uh so i i'll i'll
play the retti probably and uh and
castle up and hide in the corner as long
as i can yeah no because it is about uh
lasting as many moves as possible
definitely yeah i mean we have had one
winner uh
in that challenge two minutes on the
clock it's almost impossible ginger gm
simon williams was able to win and david
lasted
70 moves 72 moves ah i lost though
i had quite a bit of time left but i
just put my rook on a square and it just
got captured
not my finest moment
as well so don't worry yeah good so this
is not a long time my advice to you is
just to make as many moves as possible
exactly that's what i wanted
because you only have two mi two minutes
you don't have increment yeah just about
getting those moves out and you know
trying not to get checkmated
speed is good and also
play magnus the app it does create a lot
of threats so just think after they've
made a move what's the purpose if
there's something threatened move it
defend it if not then you can just as as
you mentioned this king struck this kind
of structure around your king perfect
you'll last a long long time yeah
and uh
yeah i know i like to play uh play this
one
as he has done now so you like closed
positions with lots of pawns yeah if i
i'm if i'm uncertain about your opponent
it's a safe way to start
good point but a few my mates of course
i know how they play right
quite offensive i attack immediately do
you have like chess nights with with
your friends like we know you know poker
nights is a normal thing do you guys
have like chess nights not as often as i
would like to
kids need to grow older then you can
have the regular chestnuts exactly and
also i need to bring them to just the
chess club so i can actually play more
yeah definitely i can tell you chess
knights are very popular in northern
norway i played a tournament in northern
norway and i had a lot of people come up
to me and said oh you know you wrote a
book on the karakan i was like yes yes i
did and i said we've discussed it many
times in our chess nights they have uh
we have met they had many fan people who
were fans of the karakan fans of the
book and then there are others who were
not fans and they were just in between
them they were like testing out with
computer analysis and i was like wow
nice wow this is a really hardcore but
this is how you get better at chess and
have those chess nights yeah you know
just order some pizzas in if if you like
pizzas yeah then have as much fun as
possible study in the game and wine is
allowed to you guys i would have that
but i mean that must be the thing right
regularly playing and not only maybe
online but actually making it a social
thing
oh yeah no it's much nicer yeah yeah to
sit with friends but of course you
shouldn't have too many beers that's
very important of course then you don't
remember anything except from what you
learned after that evening and of course
you want to win now when you play with
your friends i know you know these guys
playing in tournaments so much anger
when they lose or play bad moves will
you get angry when you lose or is it
just a nice thing to be with your
friends it depends if i lose because i
make a mistake then i actually get a bit
angry yeah i'm not a i'm a relatively
bad winner and bad loser so
because i do gloat and i get angry so
it's so great to hear that even the
great people from unicef have some bad
qualities
one great thing about chess is that the
rules are fairly defined and there's no
room for argument because i do know that
my husband and his friends they play
some card game dominion or something and
there's a lot of arguments about the
rules
oh chess you can't do that it's all
about your
the moves that you make yeah and that's
the beauty of it you lose because of
yourself not because your opponent did
something yeah but then you become so
naked as well become so obvious right
yeah it does reveal it does reveal your
strengths and your weaknesses and
meanwhile there have been a load of
moves on the board and
there's been some tension clarified on
the left side
yeah so we did see a trade of pawns the
first uh material to leave the board so
now there is at least one open line on
the b file uh meanwhile black did bring
his bishop to the side as we mentioned
just hinting at the idea of capturing
one of the white knights but that white
knight in the middle has been defended
and okay we're seeing a dance of the
bishops black bishop came forward
white's bishop retreated the black
bishops retreated now will white uh
bring his bishop back where it came from
that will be the second time we've seen
this position i don't think magnus wants
to repeat three times and go for the
draw i think he wants to find maybe a
different move to maintain the tension
and
just by the speed that jordan went for
that i'm slightly surprised maybe he
thinks
he would be happy to get out of here
with a draw
he is black against the world champion
after all but magnus it does give him a
chance now to maybe improve one of the
white rooks i'm looking at both rooks
they could be improved and uh okay he
brings his bishop out instead connecting
his rooks at least but it's to a more
active square than it sat on previously
and will that dance of the bishops
continue will jordan's dart squad bishop
come out
back to the edge of the board to hit
white's knight in the center on the e3
square
i i think he has to do something like
that because otherwise
he's just helped magnificently he has
exactly he's given magnus a free bishop
move
and uh that's not ideal and uh i i'd
have to say i do love it when the
viewers at home send us their pictures
of where they're watching the show from
and we have cosmon who is watching from
lisbon airport oh waiting for our flight
i love that and so a big hello hope you
make your flight looks like you're in
good time and uh enjoy the travel
destination wherever you're going to
yeah oh and um
nowadays you can probably keep watching
on the plane as well which is nice great
way to spend a long flight i would say
yeah would it be important to secure the
b line here
yes uh the white rook to secure the b
line for instance
that's a really good uh good point and
actually it's black to move right now
but i think it will become a fight for
this beeline blacks rook would love to
occupy this or at least control these
squares and likewise if magnus gets one
move i think
it's pretty definite that he's going to
plant his rook here for example if black
just takes a time out on the other side
it doesn't really improve his position
too much then white would love to
occupy and maybe even try and uh enter
black's half later in the game i think
he would love to maybe team up his rooks
as well plant this rook behind the queen
for example again if black continues not
doing much then we could see the rook
come across and white is able to open
not just the beeline but the sealed file
as well we mentioned this lock and key
situation white can open things up
by capturing in the center so again
imagine a situation where white controls
these two files it's
gonna be one way traffic here white
controls too much so that's why i think
jordan is thinking um
he's pausing right now because he's
wondering how to fight if he does bring
his rook across
i think he's just going to get
challenged anyway and this tension here
it just depends who that favors the
problem for black as well is that the
queen would love to jump forward in
order for this rook to enter the game
but if the black queen ever moves for
example comes out then it would drop
this pawn the black queen is kind of
stuck where she is
because this white bishop is so strong
so actually in this position we didn't
see jordan continue the dance of the
bishops trying to hit this knight
instead we saw him retreat his own
knight
partly blocking this bishop as we
mentioned but partly putting extra
pressure he really wants the tension to
end
he wants white to commit this pawn to
push it forward or to trade and uh okay
i just have a feeling magnus might just
try and capture this knight because now
black's pawn structure will be
compromised for example we see another
trade here these are weak these are
isolated and doubled and magnus he's
really
in kind of attuned to the opponent's
pawn structure
here long term these pawns are going to
be a real burden for black
so the current position is this one
maybe magnus will take this knight or he
could possibly delay it a bit longer and
maybe he'll just give up this pawn
because if you bring your rook across
for example as you mentioned there
in order to capture this guy black
actually needs to make some trades and
would only end up with weak doubled
pawns anyway
so for example now white can march
forward in the center white can maybe
bring his knight out we mentioned this
fiance bishop it doesn't look great it
looks like a purely defensive piece in
the current position but suddenly it
could well come to life on this diagonal
it has some targets now
so really tense but it is all about
this pawn first of all whether white
wants to move it or allow it to be
captured and then the open files and uh
yeah
it's still very tense but
i think slightly turning in magnus's
favor maybe because black's starting to
retreat pieces on every turn and magnus
might be the first to occupy good
squares with his rooks
i was just counting pieces
how many are there it's all of them on
the board they've only been one set of
pawns traded each yeah
in
17 moves how rare is that that's pretty
rare i think i want to play the game
that was 30 40 moves before the first
porn co exchange but that is once almost
once in a lifetime so that type of thing
so wow
yeah here it's it's just the nature of
the position and this is exactly the
strategy that magnus went for and that's
why we talk about white having the
advantage because as white you can
choose open sicilian really aggressive
or you can choose the retice maybe
slower passive game and uh yeah not that
passive here for magnus but you know he
really wants to do something i think
they will get the itch uh as we've
passed move 20 both players will want
some action yeah in rapid chess you
can't just maneuver forever you need to
do something yeah
and one thing i wanted to say with so
many pieces being on the board is that
uh often this uh
encourages the players just to use up
the time on the clock because they're
thinking about every single possibility
there's lots of pieces to activate
there's some potential captures i mean
and you have to think about the best
plan and again
like david mentioned it's very difficult
with this tension and it keeps
increasing increasing and often one
player will crack like you said and
that's it the
position will heat up and uh david
really summed it up like my chest you
know to move 35 that's when everything
hits the fan and normally i have no time
on the clock
and this is when blunders happened but
uh i mean yeah just wait for it this is
just a storm brewing in a tea cup
interesting yeah yeah i made the analogy
a couple of days ago it's like a staring
contest both of them are just staring at
each other neither really wants to break
eye contact or kind of kind of flinch
first so
yeah who's going to blink first is it
going to be magnus actually i got a tip
from oskil which is a great chess player
as well once that you always want your
opponent so this was a tip for beginners
have your opponent
make the first uh trade take the first
piece especially with the pawns because
then maybe you know he's the one forced
to have the double pawns for example
and they're the first ones to maybe give
ground yeah they also have to spend time
doing that the first they have to spend
the first move doing that so you have a
move before to maybe get yourself ready
for the tension to break so yeah in
general make sure every capture or every
trade is on your terms
make sure that when you recapture you
improve your position that your opponent
worsens their position uh when going for
that trade yeah and plus
at my beginner level i start if they if
they're not taking my piece you know i
get so insecure wait why are you not
taking this piece what am i missing and
then i spend all my time yeah
i once uh i once played a kind of pairs
chess game with uh
you kind of play with partners alternate
moves you were there actually kai and
play with beginners and the opponent put
the queen on a square could just be
taken for free and they didn't take
because they
they were following that rule they were
thinking okay i shouldn't make the first
capture it must be a trap yeah taking a
free queen it must be a trap
so okay meanwhile a couple of moves
white's rook actually brought itself to
the center that's surprising not
occupying the open file i think
occupying the open fire would have been
by far the most natural choice there
instead white's rook came to the center
maybe an in anticipation of things uh
kind of blowing open in the center or
the pawns getting traded but then jordan
he's maintaining the attention just
pushing a pawn and okay the action has
started it's going yeah
in the beginning uh liquor by white
knight is in the center of the board and
it's also in jordan's territory and i
think that was a reaction actually to uh
jordan's last move it looked like a
really innocuous move just uh make some
air for the king but in actual fact it
could have been signaling something very
sinister on the surface it could have
been
signaling my favorite thing in the world
a porn store
[Laughter]
maybe he might not have done it but yeah
just pushing those pawns forward and
magnus said right i'm not waiting for
this i want to do something and
now jordan has a question you know is he
going to capture the knight
uh unleash the rook sitting on the d1
square is he going to
yeah and suddenly there's an incredible
amount of tension on the pawn i don't
think you can play this at all this uh
knight is just not touchable uh the
another another move is uh
to defend the pawn that's under attack
and that's what uh jordan has done he's
uh defended the c6 pawn yeah so he's
brought his rook across but
yeah now
now magnus has captured this black
knight and i think we're going to see
some trades here and look at this magnus
is just simply going to play strategic
chess positional chess after this
capture no matter which way black takes
back okay he actually takes back with a
bishop now we see a trade of pawns and
this pawn structure i mentioned okay we
don't see a trade of pawns i was going
to say white is just going to move the
queen and these two pawns are just going
to drop off you look at this guy it's
attacked once twice three times
and instead anticipating this jordan has
actually sacrificed a pawn automatic
recapture i assumed would happen but no
he pushes forward and this is really
clever actually from the dutchman
because now he's opening up his bishops
and i think we'll see magnus start
shaking his head because now after a
trade here
all of black's pieces have improved
their quality this bishop hitting this
pawn this bishop kind of got its laser
vision along this diagonal and also the
black rook becoming super active so
jordan we talked about how he likes to
sacrifice pawns he's been working with
daniel dubois remember as part of
magnus's training camp dubov the
ultimate pawn sacrificer and suddenly
black has the better pieces and look at
that the evaluation bar all in black's
favor look at this the black bishop's
coming to life black winning the pawn
back this one has turned completely
magnus has lost control
and wow magnus has even sacrificed
material he's just given up his rook for
a bishop
and uh wow i think jordan might win this
game if you do a quick count black has a
rook for just a knight and a pawn so
knight in the pawn worth four the rook
worth five
and uh it's not just that but look how
many open lines the rooks have black's
rook is going to swing across to a
completely open file
the queen of rook on a completely open
file
wow magnus just i don't know what's
happened to him there i can't really
explain it he just underestimated the
force of black's bishops this bishop as
well look how open it is on this whole
diagonal look how blocked white's bishop
is staring at its own pawn so this one
is very one-sided now and apparently
some big reactions on uh magnus while
these moves were happening look at this
frustrated what is that about david i
think he just like me he missed that
pawn move earlier um he he just assumed
that there would be a recapture where
white would have been in complete
control but instead jordan just gave up
a pawn in order to open up his pieces
improve the quality of his pieces and
that was the reaction we saw magnus just
annoyed at himself for missing that one
move it was an easy one to miss i think
i missed it as well but uh yeah either
way he has high standards and uh okay
he's at least speeding up now he's
trying to put pressure on the clock but
white's knight has to retreat to a
really sad square just to avoid being
captured by black's bishop black can
even bully white now that he is a
head-on material he can offer these
trades constantly and what's going to
have to run away from them because
white's bishop and knight will not be
able to compete against the black rooks
later in the game yeah black's pieces
are just overwhelming and uh doesn't
really help that the two rooks have
these beautiful lines uh it's just and
especially they can go on to the second
row
bad news for magnus and the thing it
just turns in one move
it was like a collapse wasn't it yeah
and it was almost like when we saw that
video footage of magnus like he
it was almost like he made a mouse slip
or something something went wrong and
just
he's so frustrated with himself i mean
maybe we'll have to ask him later what
the reaction was about i don't i mean i
didn't see anything no i mean i would
just went through there was no way that
he could have done a mouth slip but it
was just like
such
frustration and uh wow
wow wow and we have uh so tai the stats
guy um actually before this round sent a
message saying that uh because jordan
from first one against ding in the last
round
that uh jordan from forest uh had a
better chance to qualify for knockouts
than digniran and uh
beating world number three do you think
he's now gonna also beat world number
one he's got to be a big favorite if
jordan doesn't win from here he will be
beating himself up just
about it i mean
this is not just a big big advantage but
it's very one-sided traffic look at
white's knight it's had to kind of
contort itself plant itself on the side
of the board purely on a passive square
right pawns you don't want to throw them
forward you can't push them because you
just weaken yourself the black rooks are
starting to take control
and okay white's queen as well a bit
offside on the edge of the board not
really helping out i think yeah i mean i
would be shocked if jordan doesn't win
this one to be honest the only hope for
white is that maybe he can swap off the
queens swap off one set of rooks and
hold what we call a fortress where he
just covers everything especially with
his bishop on the light squares and he
just hopes and prays that black can't
break through white does have a pawn
advantage after all so
uh it's going to be hard for black if
queens and rooks do come off to maybe
create a past pawn later in the game to
win the endgame
so okay meanwhile white's still a long
way from salvation here and black's rook
as we mentioned actually in the previous
game on the second rank that's where the
targets lie look at all the pawns look
at white's king and knight yeah
i think white's only chance is just to
be really obstinate and just defend
defend the fund and just frustrate
jordan and
just try to provoke a rash reaction so
maybe you're nick's like where's my
breakthrough why am i not winning this
and maybe you know jordan can
give back material or something just to
clarify the position and uh there magnus
um gave the well
put his queen to the eighth row and uh
jordan just simply retreats his bishop
because there is no clear-cut way right
how to break through it's just about
improving yeah just maximize the black
rooks maximize the black queen and
bishop and then look for the
breakthrough but i was going to say
magnus was moved putting the white queen
on the top of the board that's the type
of move that's intended to scare the
opponent but it's much more effective in
over-the-board chess when you move your
queen deep into that position on the
board but in online chess you realize
actually the queen's not really doing
much there it doesn't visually look so
scary and white's queen just hitting
pawns that are easily protected and now
the queen's cut off from the defense of
her king so nice move from jordan there
yeah and i think his next move is nearly
automatic black's king is just going to
slide across to the dark square because
dark squares are where black
is most is most solid and black's king
will be very safe next to its pawns
meanwhile at least magnus is activating
his knight
i'm not so sure i like uh i like the
fact that that has been allowed
but then again the knight maybe can just
be locked out of the game later on
meanwhile as predicted black's king on a
dark square if your opponent has a light
squared bishop just put your king in
under a square just to frustrate them it
will never really be in trouble
okay
the white knight has at least broken
free
knights in the center i mean it's much
better now than it was three moves ago
so how will jordan react to this
i think he's gonna put his rooks on the
second rank that's that's for me the
most natural move and
yeah just put both of them on the second
row
and no well jordan decides no that white
queen is just a little bit too
annoying so he chases it away
so the white queen back where it came
from the black rook now under fire from
white's knight
so that will move
you can gain even more time against the
white queen if you want to
it's tempting isn't it attack her one
more time and uh this time instead say
jordan decides to ask white way you want
to trade rooks
white probably will say no thank you i
think or maybe maybe you have to
actually
okay why do you have to hear your anchor
because i'm slightly worried that black
might be able to at some point double
the rooks along the bottom row
and you have to be really careful here
as magnus carson because that's exactly
where black is trying to break through
on the second row it looks nice but
white's bishop is actually covering a
lot of squares covering some important
pawns and uh maybe we can show this
because i think jordan has finally found
a winning plan or at least he's hoping
that this is a winning plan uh as
mentioned this rook is protected so you
don't necessarily need to trade yet but
at some point the rooks will come off
and this is where black is trying to
break through on the first rank the rook
is going to come down and you're going
to sneak behind
the white king to try and deliver mate
for example if the white queen tries to
counter-attack whoops it's too slow it's
too late black now is the one who's just
going to sneak behind and it's going to
be checkmate very very shortly
so yeah it's all about the first rank
can white hold his ground it doesn't
look that way because no matter what
black's rook is about to enter and uh
using this teamwork white's rook alone
cannot hold the fort
it's uh looking very grim for magnus
carson so he does trade and now he has
to be very very careful of this idea of
the root coming down
and uh okay has he moved no
it looks like this move is
a monster threat right now wow what an
interesting round this is uh heating up
to be richard report has already won his
game against
lighting g
eric hansen is looking really good for
him against wayne jones who is really
struggling in this tournament and look
at that hari krishna the bar all the way
over to his side in the game against
liam so liam
could be about to
be
have his first loss in the tournament
it's played fantastic so far
oh but the bar just went down maybe he
can save that draw oh it means it's a
sharp position potentially or maybe not
um yeah
definitely i mean one of the great
things about hari krishna is that he
made a pledge on instagram that he was
going to be donating 10
of his winnings to the unicef fund yeah
fantastic by harry krishnan and i also
know other players
are
donating uh prize money to the unicef
cause we are currently on um more than
fifty thousand dollars we have set the
aim to seventy five thousand dollars
would be great to make that today or
tomorrow
please with anything uh you can
contribute with uh please uh donate to
help unicef help the people in ukraine
so important that we come together
all right so moves david do you think
jiren will win this now looks likely and
there's actually a checkmate in one
threat on the board wow black's queen
wants to zoom across actually to the
corner square the h1 square that would
be checkmate the white king would be
trapped and the rook protects the white
the black queen so white's king has to
move out the way using the white bishop
as a defender on the light squares
covering that corner square now with the
white bishop and also if there are any
checks the white bishop maybe is able to
drop back and block so white's king
finding a safe haven temporarily on the
edge of the board on the light square
but long term
looks like that king shouldn't really
survive black's queen can give an
annoying check right now actually if you
could kind of switch the queen and rook
over maybe jordan will try and spend a
few minutes doing this if you could
switch the order of the black queen and
rook the black rook would be able to go
and sacrifice itself in the corner and
the black queen would follow up
delivering the checkmate later on so
it's just about arranging that type of
idea
maybe at some point the black bishop
will actually join in and sacrifice
itself for a pawn just to open things up
around the white king
there's no immediate win there's no
immediate breakthrough
so magnus i mean we've all been there
right we've all made mistakes blundered
got losing positions he's just trying to
be tenacious and making it as difficult
as possible for jordan especially now
that they're both around the
three-minute mark
we could still see a turnaround if black
is careless then the white
white knight might jump forward the
white queen has actually got some
attacking uh purpose
so um here i would probably just give a
check with the black queen just to see
what white has him in mind but he
retreats the whole way up the board
giving a different check different angle
and the white king now will retreat yeah
um i'm not sure i like this move
actually i mean i know i know it's a
nice
nice move nice safety first move but i
kind of thought it would be a good idea
to ask the white queen a question she's
quite well placed on the a7 square
defending and attacking at the same time
i'd like to kick her out
yeah so maybe the black rook could go to
the corner yeah her out
vertically and then initiate my my plans
the black could could retreat but you
kind of want the rook on the first rank
anyway that's where you're going to make
your breakthrough eventually
yeah i just don't like the fact that the
white knight now is actually well placed
because the white knight defensively
doing well and has some aggressive
intentions
i think jordan could have maybe reached
this type of position but with white's
knight still passive as it was earlier
and taking under three minutes jordan
from forest he seems like he's itching
to find a great move maybe heading into
an end game
yeah i mean he looks like he's slightly
frustrated with his position because it
does feel like he's super close but it's
not close enough because as david's
pointed out you know the white knights
is perfectly positioned it's a mult you
know it's a great universal piece both
offensively and defensively also the
same goes with the white queen and this
just means that the job is still not
done you know the game is not going to
win itself jordan still has to play good
moves and well he decides that the queen
is bothering him so he wants to offer a
trade there's no way that magnus will
accept that trade i don't know you've
heard that
i mentioned five minutes ago i think
white's dream scenario is just taking
the queens off the board and hoping that
it's a fortress i don't see any
breakthrough there for black okay and
there we go
um i think
maybe you could have kept the queens on
it's still not clear how black was going
to win and how black was going to check
mate but this is a good practical chance
with opposite colour bishops as well
white can hold the light squares white
will definitely be able to hold the
light squares and how is blacks uh how
is black ever going to create a firstly
a past pawn how is black ever going to
trade things off it's not possible
without opposite colour bishops and how
is black going to get his king active
it's going to take an age for black's
king
to get anywhere to help the rest of its
pieces so
um okay black's rook just sitting on an
annoying square first of all keeping an
eye on a couple of pawns
but
now jordan he was frustrated earlier
with the queens on the board finding a
winning plan i think he's going to be
even more frustrated now he can try for
the next 50 moves but he's still
an age away from creating any uh kind of
disturbance to the white pieces
and also the white knight if you ever
kick it away pushing a pawn the white
knight will jump into some even better
squares
well the bar is still liking it for
jordan from forest i guess this is quite
hard to play though and well kira are
you with end games do you even get to
the end game
yeah and i i like them but the best oh
yeah if i have
good time yeah because that's when when
i feel challenged that's when i can i
can think i'm a bit stressed when
there's too many pieces yeah yeah it's
too much to think about so a situation
like this i would love it and then good
man
i agree i mean getting the pieces off so
you don't have to think about
too much at all times but then again
having some time on the clock to
actually think about what to do and
magnus is laughing here what is that
about he often does that
and does he often play bad moves after
that david yeah we've noticed a pattern
magnus often struggles after he's been
eating noodles as we've seen
and after he laughs to himself there's
often a mistake coming uh after that
maybe just losing a little bit of focus
highly unofficial um
what do we call it
analysis by us yeah
we haven't checked out the stats we just
uh admire him laughing and
yeah
and uh okay meanwhile maybe he's been
laughing just because he thinks he's got
away with it maybe he thinks he's got
out of jail but a long battle ahead note
how white is just sit going up and down
with the king
magnus is going to try and do that
forever because the white bishop can't
move the white knight is on its
well it's on a decent square and the one
thing you don't want to do with white is
push any pawns because actually that
would just leave weaknesses behind
at the moment white's pawn structure
they all defend each other they defend
they're defended by their bishop if you
push pawns forward the black bishop
might be able to start targeting
targeting things you know i think i
figured out what he was laughing about i
think it's an inside joke
i mean during the team there's a lot of
banter maybe there was some joke about
you know you're not being great at end
games or something and so he's like
thinking back to that laughing
yeah quite possibly probably and then uh
yeah i mean there's only one punching
bag in this end game though and that's
magnus so roles have reversed
and uh yeah jordan i did mention just
before the game as well end games this
is one
this is one area maybe
i've played him a few times in classical
chess over the board and every time i've
taken it into dryer end games i've
managed to win
he's held a couple of draws but
in that blitz match as well every time i
just tried to swap the queens as early
as possible and i was able to
knock him out of that tournament so
engage is his one
area maybe
and still i mean this is a difficult end
game because it's not conventional it's
not a typical kind of pawn race with
pawns racing up the board that you can
calculate it's not a typical position
that you can just memorize because this
is still i mean lots and lots of pieces
on the board i don't think either player
has had anything similar to this in
their careers it's very much purely
about the planning long term where does
black's king want to be when he pushes
pawns where does black bishop want to be
where does the black rook
want to be as well and well okay he does
push a pawn
i just said don't do this
and uh i'm wondering why maybe he
thought he needed to do it eventually
but now the rook can come down to the
second rank all of white's pawns on the
right half of the board now they're on
dark squares so they are actually
targets
this is surprising to me
maybe he just maybe he thinks the black
bishop doesn't have any good uh kind of
avenues now
to annoy the white pawns to attack the
white pawns and there's also no way
forward for the black king
well it's a deep deep analysis there
because um i would not have pushed that
pawn as well because white's pawn
structure looked so compact and so
well defended by the light square bishop
now it feels a little bit shaky
especially if a black bishop were to get
to the e1 square and this is why magnus
puts his king on the f1 but okay black
still has lots of plans you know he can
mobilize the king another one would be
you know just
do a little bit of a journey and try to
support a pawn advance
yeah so two possible winning plans here
for jordan this game is going to go on a
long long time i feel uh two potential
winning plans you mentioned one of them
there your anchor is actually to retreat
the black king to actually plant it on
this square for example if white weights
okay he's not going for this yet but if
white waits you plant the king here and
then eventually you start pushing your
pawns and slowly but surely you want to
connect the pawns so any pawn capture is
met by another pawn capture and uh again
if white waits then suddenly at least
you're making progress you're maybe
going to trade a pawn maybe going to
dislodge this white oh sorry dislodge
this white bishop
lots of moves happening but not changing
the nature of the position so let's just
discuss the plans so black could push
pawns this is plan one and then plan two
the one i'm maybe slightly more
attracted to but it's harder to achieve
if we go back to the current position is
to
go on a bit of a king march okay he's
going for plan one i think bring his
king to the side uh you have to defend
this pawn first uh before you push pawns
i was gonna say plan two was to go on a
king march you go round the whole way
you might have to take the long route
round but then eventually start creeping
into white's position maybe from the
side and use the king as another
attacker but it's not clear whether you
could achieve that whether you have
enough time
and uh meanwhile if we catch up with
play this is the current position note
how the knight is just keeping an eye on
these pawns
if you ever push them
for example
if white waits if you ever push these
pawns then you just leave holes
sorry here for the white knight to jump
into
the okay a maneuvering battle
has commenced
we're going to be here do you think 100
moves ivanka yeah
i suspect that jordan's going to go for
plan one
and when it doesn't work he will now go
for plan 2 and march the king on its
odyssey and try to see how far up the
board it will go
and then if it doesn't get very far
perhaps
agree a draw
never never okay for that one jordan
yeah i would maybe do it the other way
around because pushing pawns is more
committal uh once you've pushed pawns
they won't retreat they won't keep each
other safe anymore so i would maybe
start by bringing the king the whole way
around if there's no way for the king to
get in then i would go back the whole
way with the king and then push the
points
but then you might have reached me 15.
i'm not so sure
chess is a long game
50 moves is a long time so
okay meanwhile
rook's moving king's moving also magnus
did push a pawn on move 52 okay so if
there are no more pawn pushers or
captures for the next 40 moves
by the time we get to move 102 it's a
draw so he has 40 moves in order to
arrange a pawn push
that's enough time
even if he dances around with the king
for a while and there we go the king's
going is it going the whole way around
here you go here we go clearly
and he's using the dark squares
just avoiding any potential checks from
the white bishop
and uh it's a long long way to get into
the heart of white's position and even
if the black king if you could pick it
up and put it maybe on the d2 square
it's still not attacking anything so
um
at least it's a plan to maybe annoy
magnus disrupt his defensive formation
and uh here we go magnus just moving his
bishop not committing yet
okay well we'll see the king
move a little bit no the rooker improves
itself to a dark square very safe yep
everything on dart squares is a logical
uh setup for black
and magnus is just going to sit and wait
and look at jordan he can definitely
feel the pressure uh one minute and 42
seconds left on the clock
how big would it be for jordan to win
this game i mean has he often has he
ever beaten magnus um on the off the top
of my head i can't recall a time that uh
jordan's beaten magnus no at least in a
tournament game maybe in their sparring
sessions at training camps he's won a
few games here and there but yeah uh no
magnus is still very much top dog i
think in this rivalry
jordan maybe he's actually the bogeyman
the the kind of kryptonite for any giri
he's beaten him a few times in vaikansei
but uh magnus is a different kettle of
fish so i think a big big game for
jordan a meaningful one
if he gets the win all right
well
good news for him magnus carlsen is now
thinking one minute a bunch of games
have ended richard report has won his
game
eric hanson won the game against gawain
jones and then two other games is also
still going on it's looking good for
young christophe duda against joe and
jun
and the bar has been two navara's side
all the time in the game against
pragnanda
maybe the young
indian player is saving a draw in this
game keep an eye on that as well
yeah meanwhile just one bishop moved by
magnus
not changing things too much
jordan yeah moving his rook there
we are getting closer to that 100 move
mark
slowly but surely
and the one problem for black is if he
does bring his king the whole way round
if there's no way through and if he has
to bring the king the whole way back
again
by then we might have reached 80 90.
and uh well magnus is proactively
stopping the king from marching because
he's put his bishop
in the eye line of uh the e8 square
which will be the square that targets
the black pawns yeah and really sneaky
here from magnus there is a bit of a
well i won't say trap but uh there is a
trick so he's offered up a pawn as bait
in the center of the board black's rook
on the d-file can actually go up and
capture a white's pawn in the middle but
then the white bishop would just drop
back one square and once the rook moves
the white bishop is going to start
taking black's pawns on the king side
black's pawns all on light squares
if you notice so
maybe we can just show this on the board
because jordan you saw him just for a
moment he thought that magnus had
blundered
but uh this is too simple a position for
magnus to blunder if black takes this
pawn in the center then the bishop does
okay he's done it the bishop does drop
back and we're going to see a skewer
here and okay this is a rook check the
king now is it gonna move wow we could
see a really weird scenario the king now
if it goes this way black has time to
defend his pawn with his king if it goes
this way okay this is really heating up
now the rook's gonna come across and
attack the white knight
suddenly not so easy at all but could
the road get
trapped there's chances the rook might
get trapped uh i mean it's in no man's
land right now you could even see a
situation where white even for example
grabs a pawn and then okay he hasn't
gone for this and then just retreats
with his bishop yeah this is what he
keeps
the rook cannot actually move but maybe
black can break his rook out of jail by
taking some pawns so okay white's knight
did move maybe magnus tried to be a bit
too clever i was praising him but
in this position his knight was under
fire he brought it forward now jordan
has kept horn safe
and suddenly black has won a pawn in the
process this pawn in the center of the
board has just disappeared
still some chances for white because
these pawns are vulnerable especially to
the white bishop later on but okay
jordan must be very confident about
serious leap forward and it definitely
will be affecting the flow and the
momentum and also the psychology of the
players because
magnus will be feeling that he's on a
bit of a downward spiral
and now this rook is under attack black
just needs to move it somewhere safe put
it on a dart square
and uh again the knight attacked
suddenly
it's equal number of pawns so black has
made a huge leap
do you think he's winning now
i think objectively if it was two
computers against each other i think
black would win
but this is uh very much a human game so
uh still some chances for white and it's
gonna still take a long long time for
black's pawns to push
um i think we've chosen the longest game
of the round maybe of the charity cup so
far wow
and okay a check from magnus the black
king is gonna move and i think magnus's
idea is to actually use the white knight
and put it in the corner of the board
the h8 square to go after some of
black's pawns because the one thing
magnus doesn't want to do is trade off
his knight for the black bishop
swapping pieces here would only make
things easier for black
so black's king
under check
and where to move to because the most
natural square is to put it on a dark
square attack the
knight
but uh when the knight goes to the
corner of the board
it will move
with check from that square
that's
that's exactly why jordan's hesitating
and maybe he chooses a good square on a
light square so not ideal but at least
there are no night checks in the near
future evaluation bar though not a fan
i think magnus has to try and remove
pawns from the board as quickly as
possible because if black gets organized
now
it's just a matter of time and he does
go into the corner
and uh yeah don't try this at home
anyone never put your night in the
corner unless you really really have to
unless there's a specific purpose
but uh at least now black's pawns
have been forced to step forward so they
are loose on the light squares but i do
hope kira tries out this tactic in his
uh charity games 73 moves here that
would be uh quite a big donation for
unicef
that would be
so okay so what is it from this game
like here we can sort of take into
trying to just get as many moves as
possible on the board i think uh i think
we've already discussed it it's all
about that safe king for white yeah
keeping the white king safe in this
opening structure even if things go
wrong like they have for magnus i mean
you can survive 75 moves maybe get the
queens off as well in general
if you're unsure
and
just keep everything protected that's
what magnus is doing right now
and jordan the clock is ticking down
under 20 seconds and he has to make a
move i mean the great thing about his
position is he can make some random pass
moves like he's doing right now with the
bishop
and okay
so this bishop move
doesn't really do anything but it does
have one tiny threat and that is that
the white king cannot move to the second
row
yeah so the white king has to stop the
black bishop from coming behind the
white pawns and starting to capture them
then they'll just start falling like
domino's so
okay the white bishop meanwhile hitting
black's only pawn on the light square
and this is annoying for jordan because
he could block the attack of that bishop
but then once the bishop moves black
will have two he does this black now has
two pawns on light squares though and
they're going to be hard to defend
white's night now threatens to drop back
and start attacking those pawns
okay the bishop forced to drop back
itself suddenly those pawns on the right
side they are vulnerable to white's
bishop
okay it does feel like magnus as soon as
he dropped that pawn earlier he's been
working his magic once more uh he's no
he didn't go for the passive just sit
and wait technique that we were
advocating he's actually trying to make
things happen he's trying to force the
draw maybe playing on jordan's clock
time
and i just want to mention you guys a
big result jiu gwen jun winning her
first game in the tournament against
young christoph duda wow i've been just
looking at the bar in that game it's
been going from side to side eventually
joo and jun
getting her first win that's great
excellent news yeah and uh of course
young christopher duda is a fantastic
player really it is a really wonderful
result i hope it's the start of a
pattern for jew engine yeah i would love
to see her do really well and actually
the women's world champion that she
ended the game with checkmate she
checkmated duda in the final move
trapping his king in the corner so we
like it great result for her
and okay meanwhile big development in
this game we are seeing that trade
earlier i said the white knight
definitely doesn't want to trade off for
the black bishop and usually that's the
case but now the white bishop is able to
go for these black pawns
and uh yeah this is why maybe jordan
should have tried to prevent or should
have tried to kind of restrain his own
pawns not put them on the light squares
and uh okay magnus is starting to
eliminate the material if all of the
pawns disappear by the way if white four
and black's three disappear rook against
bishop is a simple draw
well i say simple still possible to lose
it but uh at this level jordan uh sorry
magnus would be able to hold oh
he puts uh another pawn on the light
square i was a bit surprised by that one
because i thought maybe a king would
love to be on that square yeah really
committal from jordan i'm not sure he's
going to
look back on that decision fondly
putting all of the black pawns now
as targets for the white bishop and
magnus he's just fixed his bishop where
it is
so now that bishop eternally is going to
attack the black pawns one of black's
pieces the king or rook will be stuck
defending them
and magnus is just going to wait with
his king forever
and uh
there we go it's the waiting game again
and magnus leaning back body language
he thinks he's making the draw
i honestly don't see a way forward for
black because you know
the king is forced to keep an eye on the
pawn on h5
the rook is not going anywhere by itself
it needs teamwork and of course the rick
is also tied down to the defense of the
light squared ones so i just think
they're going to repeat moves yeah and
white is never going to run out of moose
and reach something we call zugswang
where every move white makes would works
worse in his position because he can
wait with the king or with a bishop
and okay this is the second time we've
seen this position we're about to get
the draw there we go magnus miraculously
holds and shaking his head magnus
crossing eventually though after being
in big trouble he saves the draw against
jordan from forest